hello I'm Bob Ross starting with a
titanium white what do I want for my
white I think I'm going to go with queso
blanco sauce I'm going with sour cream
baby look at that oh look at that I
immediately regret this cuz the smells
are going to be rough that's part of the
pleasure of the
medium it's smooshing bro we don't we
don't make mistakes oh it smells really
bad we have happy
accidents
welcome to Bob Ross with sauce where we
follow along with one of the world's
greatest painters using nothing but food
sauce today it's art sauce all right
let's find the sauce department now we
spent hours scouring the grocery store
looking for the best pigments that we
could
find molasses we we still definitely
need blues and we need a forest green
too and now we have our variety of
sauces right here in front of us and I'm
very excited to get started the
challenge is how do you get Blues how do
you get greens how do you get reds what
do you use water-based sauces oilbased
sauces will it even work well the best
painting will be judged by its palette
both color and taste oh oh
God ready so let's get together and
let's do a fantastic painting are you
guys ready no yes I'm ready how ready
can you be for something like this I was
born ready I'm going to start off today
with a with a small amount of phthalo
blue let's start right up in here and
use little little crisscross Strokes
dude my frosting my cake icing is
already like my frosting is already
brother oh no all right pause I need to
mix it dude oh that's really bad this is
a bad move dude do we have raspberry can
I pivot this fatal blue ISM very
pretty it's all about look at that it's
work I need more blue you see I think I
might have a leg up in this competition
because I'm an actual certified Artist
as in I got a art degree from the
University of Wisconsin Madison did you
also get an art degree I I did I am an
oil painter I'm a watercolor painter I'm
an acrylic painter I'm a gouache painter
and today I'm a sauce painter I guess
this this area over here is where all
the cool paintings are just continually
use these little crisscross strokes and
allow the color to it it just literally
blends with a liquid white we're not on
a team or anything yeah but but we have
something to prove I can respect
Griffin's sort of like pedigree here but
I've been living in the land of sauce
the great state of Texas where you can
pretty much find a sauce for anything
out there so I have over three uh
paintings that made it on the fridge
over three I think when it comes to this
playing field it's pretty level no one's
worked with sauce quite like this before
so we'll just pull right across like
this oh he's doing the whole
thing mix your blue
with that's team talk brother oh
man oh it smells really bad the queso
the queso smells awful what what is that
it's the queso sauce you started with
cheese who starts with cheese end with
cheese that guy crazy dude then very
gently we'll blend it to take out the
brush strokes and right across the
bottom the the salsa mixing the frosting
is so dude this it's working this smells
like changing table D let's make it
let's make some big fluffy clouds today
I'm going go right into the titanium
white with a 1-in brush pick the sour
cream actually helps give a little bit
of uh moisture to it that it's
needed I need to bring that 3D back in
dude this is this is my department you
have to make you have to make an
Almighty decision where's your Mountain
live I think he's going to live he is
now right there two three four where you
going where are we going Bob take me
with you just s to make a
decision mountains grow in all kinds of
shapes and colors the wash cup
man so let's go right here touch no
pressure just the weight of the knife no
pressure every time I try to like add
another layer it just like wipes just
like smears more stuff across it trying
man yeah there's a lot of sour cream on
it theal Misty
Mountains covered by a thin layer of
queso oh wait we got
look I just found some white icing here
this might give me the like up no one
knows it's here I'm going to add the
least little touch least little touch a
sap green just to give it a little
greenish color switching colors
boys oh it stinks dude so sour just
really loaded full of paint oh I'm
actually kind of getting close to his
color here that's sour cream and
frosting and chocolate sauce let's say a
little footy Hill lives right here and
all I'm doing is just tapping is that
fantastic just F wipes right off the
canas doesn't it's not on a stick this
just cuts right through the
frosting it's not working I thought this
was going to look super jacked up
they're doing a great job this is like
something you'd see on the inside of a
public stall
bathroom that Fantastic look at all the
little little things it makes in there
this is like something you tell your
doctor
about this looks so bad greens that live
back here in the distance here I'm just
going to take and tap downward just the
little trees they're not all Evergreens
maybe there's all kind of
trees I'm like actually a pretty big fan
of how these trees are turning out yeah
that that like unironically looks sweet
holy Nico look at this guy I don't want
to see it I don't want to see kiding me
now then come straight into the canvas
push very firmly and just cut in a happy
little waterline nice
fide the Bock dude I'm thinking about a
lot of things right now rethinking All
My Life Choices then just the corner the
brush begin working back and forth and
we got to put some arms on this tree I
think I discovered something with
molasses and chocolate sauce like and
I'm mixing the frosting in with that to
get the screen here it's got like it's
got the paint stickiness you know yeah
you just got to let it do its thing it's
all brown no matter what I do it's all
brown reach up here and grab some sap
green I got to say I've learned for sure
to not try and like get fancy and mix
the paints like just find the thing
that's green and use the green cuz
everything else that I've tried to do is
just Brown so putting yellow and green
together yellow and green haven't seen
that yet what you doing Bob what are you
doing Bob what you doing stop it right
there Bob let's put some leaves on this
this is what begins bringing this
painting
alive and worry about little forms here
don't
just dude what the hell get Al with this
guy H just follow along with Bob Ross
tutorial it's just you just just paint
what he paints hard like really good how
much better could it be than this it's
good seriously how much better could it
be it's better AR just a subjective
medium don't don't go too crazy with
this red CU it'll it's a
fireball this is so
gross oh let's go right in here and
maybe there's a happy little path see
how easy little path is to
make there he goes and we going to let
him go around behind that tree we don't
know where it
goes what are you doing Jordan I'm
letting gravity do the work brother what
are you doing it's a real world
simulation brother look how dark that is
I can't get that dark that let's sign
this we'll call it finished sign it is
that your
sign final touches
boys we did it we did it that was
actually really fun yeah it it worked a
lot lot better than I thought it was
going to it worked it
worked wao actually wait
what wow these are all
amazing that case on might cost you the
whole
thing ooh that tree smells delicious
smells like cake so this is practiced to
learn the medium but next time I expect
Perfection a chef only wants the most
delicious paintings in this house yes
chef yes we've gotten past the Steep
learning curve now it's time to do your
absolute best and that one's going to go
up right here in the studio I'm going
tap a little bit of Indian yellow into
it don't need a lot of color you said to
start off with uh some sour cream on
your canvas is a thin coat maybe the
sun's here and it's shining out and it's
a beautiful day we'll do this painting
mostly in brown tones maybe there's a
little stand of trees that live right
here we've all learned something about
our ourselves in that last round and
we're using it in this one I don't know
if it's working out for me but I'm more
Zen this time which I think is the point
okay let's have some fun there's some
little Foothills that live back here I
feel like maybe I feel like art maybe
isn't for me dude look at this explosion
I got down at the bottom I want the
indication of a little bit of grassy
area that lives right along in here you
know I'm having trouble getting the
saturation of color that he's getting
it's almost like he has real paint yeah
I do keep forgetting we're using sauce
I'm like how does he do that got my
Hershey's freaking Sunday dream maybe up
here on the top of our little Hill yeah
you guessed it happy little tree I'm
really liking the challenge and like
this is really all about like painting
and then anticipating like 20 minutes
from now where the sauce will actually
be sitting on the canvas cuz it slowly
drips down the whole thing but it's
definitely like the toxic version of a b
Ros landscape and let's just paint us in
quick little house oh he's going to do a
house no Bob no Bob this is just a happy
little house up here on the hill god
dude I just finished making the greatest
tree I've ever made and now I got to
cover it with a cabin dude and I think
with that shoot we about got to finish
painting just signing this masterpiece
so everyone knows from all of us here
I'd like to wish you happy painting and
God bless my
friend woo come on
baby okay we took everything we learned
from the first round and we spent the
last hour of doing a competition round
which I think turned out phenomenally
now it's Ren's turn to decide who made
the best painting and that person gets
their painting put up anywhere they want
in the studio and go for
it
whoa dude wait what what it's the brown
palette here that uh looks like maybe
you're smearing something other other
than Hershey's chocolate if you know
what I mean dude these are nuts Griffin
I like this tree I like this big bold
tree that you got in the foreground here
in the little road going up to the house
I made two pretty rough paintings but
what I've learned is that from sitting
down with my friends with Bob Ross and
just getting into the spirit of painting
I really capture something beautiful
here with all of you I should I should
win for that I
should honestly nio the depth you have
in this painting is actually impressive
I can feel the distance to the distant
mountains there like the grass in the
foreground has texture and variety to it
which I find really impressive thank you
R the way I combined sauces here was
really just an attempt to try to get the
audience to subscribe to the Channel
Jake I can feel the texture of the wood
in your house here look at that and I
like the dappled leaves of your tree you
know the Special Sauce behind following
along with Bob Ross is not in fact in
doing a carbon copy it's about the
essence of painting and finding the joy
in your painting I think it worked out
well well
Jordan yes
R
uh if you want photo realism just take a
picture you know what this is this is
expressionism this is a piece of my soul
and after painting this for you I'm
exhausted golly this guy what a stretch
so that's how desperate I am man this is
tough this is tough I'm going to narrow
it down to two first then which everyone
tastes better is going to win I love it
that's good Jake you're one of the two
because that house in that tree here the
other winner is Jordan's boss
Nico Oh I thought you had Vision Ren why
did I let myself get excited so I have
to now taste these two paintings yeah
see what kind of taste and art you
have oh God oh
God why is it
spicy I used the cake icing to give it
the green but then I used the tanero
sauce to give it
texture all right Nico you're up next
bone Appetit wow yeah what part looks
the most icy where does your heart want
to
lick he took out the green he took out
the green he out the green wait
no after taste after taste he's going
back for
second it was the mustard I got a little
bit of mustard aftertaste there and I
love mustard you love mustard he loves
mustard team sheets that was the wildest
mix of flavors I've ever tasted Nico my
taste in you I tasted you wait
no Nico congrats I think we're going to
have to preserve your art forever
now that was delicious but you know what
I'm still hungry if you have any ideas
for future Bob Ross with sauce episodes
let me know cuz I think we can improve
some of the pallets here with some
better
sauces